[Aplausos]
[Música]
hola
bueno yo soy biólogo
me dedico a los árboles
y antes de que yo preparar esta plática
para todos ustedes
estuve yo pensando bueno y porque me
dedico a los árboles y soy biólogo desde
dónde surge todo esto
y bueno pues todo surge porque en mi
infancia yo estuve muy cercano a los
árboles
y cuando eran las largas vacaciones de
verano
esto lo atribuyó a que no había como
campamentos de verano como ahora es
costumbre y entonces
las las veces que teníamos que salir y
nos nos llevaban por ejemplo para para
cuidarnos era con otros familiares en
zonas rurales donde había vegetación y
había naturaleza que era muy accesible
entonces siempre me la pasaba ahí y
entonces recuerdo que
que cuando llegamos a la casa de mi
abuela materna siempre había un árbol
muy grande de mango y el reto con los
primos era ver quién trepaba primero el
árbol
y así era todo el tiempo bueno ya tiempo
después pero ya en la ciudad de mexico
donde yo crecí
y la influencia que tuve con esto de los
árboles también fue por mi padre
él tenía un negocio de plantas
artificiales
y si se consistía en
incrustar o poder poner en entroncó
naturales follaje artificial para darles
forma
y resulta que yo le ayudaba a eso pero
también a buscar los troncos y a veces
era deber buscarle por donde puedas en
la calle troncos estén muertos troncos
secos sí y ahí estábamos y uno de los
recuerdos que tengo con estos de los
árboles es que yo me encontraba
muchas veces disfrutando de jugar como
uno era niño
en medio de esa selva artificial
en la sala de mi casa con todos esos
árboles que estaban por entregarse
y bueno pues eso eso ha sido como que un
poco la historia y además el yo después
me puse a construir un poco más sobre el
conocimiento de los árboles ya me
dediqué más a mi profesión y resulta que
después yo me encuentro trepado también
en los árboles en la maestría no pero
ahora instalando sensores para poder
saber cómo es el 12 el y cómo funcionan
los árboles desde el punto de vista
fisiológico y entonces ahí estaba
atrapado con todos los problemas de
poderse caer pero bueno así son los
gajes del oficio de los biólogos no
entonces
desde desde desde aquel desde aquella
época yo me enfrentaba a una pregunta
que todavía me la sigo haciendo cómo es
que se enfrentan los árboles
constantemente ali a la problemática de
la sobrevivencia y del desarrollo que
ellos deben de tener entonces bueno
sabemos bien que hay muchos estudios
sobre esto este muchos tipos de árboles
y especies entonces
otra pregunta que yo me hacía era bueno
cuáles son los lugares más difíciles en
donde los aros donde los árboles deben
de sobrevivir o existen y uno de estos
ecosistemas o hábitats que yo siempre he
pensado es que son las ciudades
justamente entonces en las ciudades los
árboles deben de enfrentar un aire
constantemente caliente
y una atmósfera saturada de
contaminantes
deben de enfrentar constante manejo
también
y
y entonces con estas con esta pregunta
ustedes se pueden imaginar bueno pues
los árboles urbanos pues ahorita en la
mente nos nos viene por ejemplo un
parque urbano o un jardín este
inmediatamente pero
a los árboles en un lugar como estos por
ejemplo están muy consentidos porque
porque les procuran riego les tienen
cierto mantenimiento y las zonas
arboladas las especies o los los
individuos se acompañan unos entre otros
y entonces tienen una forma de
protección entre sí
entonces no del todo es una zona difícil
para que vivan los árboles entonces la
siguiente pregunta es cuáles son los
lugares más difíciles dentro de una
ciudad para unos árboles
yo les apuesto ahorita
todos nosotros pasamos todos los días
por lugares en donde se encuentran estos
árboles y ni nos damos cuenta estos
árboles son del espacio de banqueta del
área de banqueta
y
y entonces estos árboles son los
los que son los que constantemente se
encuentran en condiciones estresantes
porque porque están limitados en el
espacio está en la parte de abajo del
sistema radicular pero también en la
parte de arriba de una copa también es
estresan constantemente
cuando absorben el agua en la deben de
absorber de donde puedan porque porque
están rodeados de una plancha de
concreto así abominable no entonces
bueno pues si no sé si son más
estresantes estas estructuras y ya tengo
estas este árboles y estos sitios todo
esto llegó a cristalizarse
un proyecto que yo es yo estoy
encabezando y que ya terminamos de hacer
todo el estudio
que consistió en hacer todo el registro
el análisis y la evaluación y la
identificación de especies de todos los
árboles de banqueta de la ciudad de san
luis potosí
actualmente ya hemos terminado
aunque suene demasiado nos ha llevado
aproximadamente como un año y medio este
no ha sido sencillo pero si les puedo
decir que ya hemos terminado y que
entonces hemos tenido experiencias
fabulosas unas de las experiencias que
hemos tenido es que la gente
cuando íbamos a medir un árbol se
acercaba y decía bueno a ver qué estás
haciendo no otro de los riesgos de ser
el color urbano es que en esas ocasiones
pues también llamaban a la policía y nos
querían meter al bote porque pues que
estábamos haciendo ahí
la libramos nunca fui a la cárcel
pero entonces
lo que me platicaban cuando salí a la
gente en esa interacción conversábamos y
ya les decía pues es que estamos
haciendo esto ya la la y nos platicaban
que estos grandes árboles éste los
habían sembrado sus abuelos sus papás
hace 80 hace de 50 años y entonces la
gente procura los árboles porque les
tiene un valor estimativo muy fuerte y
los procura y hasta los éste considera
suyos los árboles entonces prácticamente
hemos visto muchas cosas por ejemplo
como pequeños huertos urbanos en donde
se encuentra una granada un limón
etcétera
y son especies valiosas y en el registro
que hemos hecho de este conteo pues
resulta que tenemos muchas especies de
árboles ornamentales
pero también especies
tropicales especies medicinales especies
comestibles obviamente y entonces el
arbolado en estos espacios tiene un
valor cultural un valor ambiental
también y bueno está sentimental no
resulta que
que también hemos podido detectar
la gente
puede bueno en este momento más bien voy
a hacer una analogía extrema significa
que
los árboles yo considero que también son
como las mascotas como los perros y los
gatos es decir cuando son pequeñas
plántulas y se encuentran pequeñitas
todo el mundo se las lleva bueno hasta
en el escritorio se encuentran las
plantitas y está muy padre pero entonces
luego las plantas que éste crece el
árbol y así como los este cachorros pues
se olvidan del perro ya después que
creció porque porque ya no está tan
chistoso ya no internarse tanto no y
resulta que entonces los árboles cuando
crecen pues ya levantó la banqueta ya me
tapo la luz de la casa este ya ya lo
tenemos que poder porque estorba
etcétera etcétera y resulta que las
personas nos decían pues si es que yo
pensaba que no iba a crecer tanto es que
el jardinero me dijo que no no iba a
crecer muy poquito baja
pues bueno otra de las cosas que tiene
estos de la plática con la gente es que
también se piensa que los árboles pueden
dañar las estructuras de las casas si
les puedo decir que hay muy pocos
reportes científicos en donde se
comprueba que un árbol puede dañar la
estructura de una casa si todo de rubio
derribarla mucho menos este pero por
ejemplo aquí en san luís potosí
con este estudio también detectamos que
hay árboles de 25 a 30 metros de altura
con copas muy desarrolladas en la calle
y la casa o la edificación que está
contigua no no tiene daños aparentes sí
claro que no soy especialista en eso
pero si se requiere más investigación
interdisciplinaria en ese sentido
bueno ok entonces
está esta situación de los árboles
también tiene una connotación en cuanto
a qué
la gente también tiene el sentido de la
estética con esto de los árboles y
piensa entonces que hay que hacerle
modificaciones y entonces los pondrán
como con esferas o cubos o formas de
animales también no porque no pero
entonces cuando hacen esas grandes
modificaciones de la estructura y de la
de la copa de un árbol lo que pasa es
que están eliminando las funciones tan
importantes de un árbol que sí que está
en el follaje por qué porque entonces un
árbol ya no puede realizar todos esos
esos mecanismos y esos mecanismos son
producir oxígeno al aire absorber el
dióxido de carbono que están saturado en
un ambiente urbano
por ejemplo mitigar las condiciones de
las altas temperaturas en el aire etc
los árboles brindan muchas funciones en
ese sentido
y bueno para finalizar si les tengo que
decir que hemos concluido todo este todo
este proyecto y que la biodiversidad en
san luís potosí si consiste en mucho de
especies ornamentales más que nativas
pero no es despreciable los valores que
nosotros hemos encontrado porque porque
tenemos una gran cantidad de especies
que por ese valor cultural la gente ha
procurado
y entonces tengo que decir que también
en el espacio de banqueta los árboles
aunque están confinados en ese espacio
tan limitado
y tan estresante de todos modos tienen
un gran potencial desde el punto de
vista
cultural desde el punto de vista
ambiental y desde el punto de vista
ecológico
entonces yo me quedo con la reflexión de
que los los árboles
en esta situación pueden llegar a tener
un solo árbol puede llegar a tener
beneficios inmediatos en su espacio más
cercano sí
pero si esto lo traducimos a que todos
los árboles están bien conservados en
una cuadra o en una colonia entonces
estamos hablando de servicios
ambientales para una gran cantidad de
población y dado que la ciudad de san
luis potosí requiere muchos de estos
servicios ambientales
es necesario entonces conservarlos
entonces mi propuesta es
sigamos plantando árboles no se van a
caer nuestras casas
pero que entonces las ventajas son
poderles dar ese es el mantenimiento
directo personalizado casi como lo hemos
visto
y que las desventajas pudieran ser que
bueno a lo mejor no sabemos tanto de las
prácticas de manejo de poda de un árbol
pero sí habría que acercarse un poco más
al agente profesional y bueno me quedo
con esa idea muchas gracias
[Aplausos]